my grandfather was a really famous
surgeon now I don't want to I kick off
like this well my great-grand your back
dude your back I'm back you're back you
must miss mom the middle of a story and
I was gonna tell him and then we're like
let's just roll I'm back from Calgary
Calgary thank you yes man beautiful
place did you try the Chinese food next
door didn't to spite you
[ __ ] you me right now I'm so delicious
it's so unhealthy the sweet sour chicken
it's like old school grimy Chinese well
Oh Bry O'Brien's into a couple things
I'm gonna sound Oh Bryson the
intermittent fasting of course cuz I'm a
[ __ ] hold on no I know 2011 I'm cool
yeah no Bryan just fat come on okay no
thank you come on don't call 2011
honesty mm well I don't know if you've
heard of this thing called intermittent
fasting which is all they talk about so
good old bride at the pigeon-holed G
divisional best restaurant in Calgary in
my opinion no I only know that Chinese
food well see and you say Chinese food
the explanation explanation I was like
not gonna do it now you [ __ ] up not
gonna do it I can't believe they didn't
offer it to you I keep my body very very
open and whole you know kitchen holds
the [ __ ] that's a great restaurant now
oh I have been there for breakfast yes
great ass [ __ ] great breakfast I have
been there for breakfast and pigeon the
whole yep outstanding go there again you
won't eat the Chinese food you'll go to
Pigeon nope I love the choice nvidia
casino there no that casino by the way
gusting I walked I've seen better skin
on elephants than the people there I've
seen better skin on [ __ ] elephants
like how it everybody in that room has a
limp away that is zero ones calves are
super swollen
you know how in the cow cow cow might be
with us when the calf's are social and
they hang over the socks they should
call you like you've put if you put
socks on hippo yeah that's what it's the
elbow casino it should be called all the
wrong choices oh yeah I made all the
wrong choices
no it's all the mutants of Calgary it's
crazy you go in there and you're like
dude you're on an oxygen happy you're
smoking and you're pulling that chain
chain chain it's it's I couldn't get out
of there I had to walk through it to get
to the
I had to outside I literally had to I
had to walk through a sage cloud I
needed a shaman to cleanse the bad
energy off of me
[ __ ] there's one thing about Canada
there's no middle ground
they either and the majority people are
a great-lookin and then they're ugly
people the ugly's you ever see in the
world well I think it's the the winners
are so long and hard like I went to
middle pretty people do during that
winter they bring up Manitoba I went to
Manitoba to do stand-up I had a great
time with that town at least when I was
there it is doesn't look to run down
there but Zen hello man oh yeah I love
Canada no I'm against Stillwater
Oklahoma I went back there without you
is it Stillwater yeah that little town
is beautiful though isn't it little
towns beautiful however however however
it looks like the extras from walking
debt yeah or the extras from Lord of the
Rings
tell me you got works you got people who
look and they all do respect but some
people are not it's over dude some
people Oklahoma and certain people there
are certain parts of America Canada's
beautiful certain parts of America
certain parts of Canada I think Hanna
has the most beautiful people however
yeah they're the most ugliest people as
well
I'm gonna say no middle girl she bred
I'm gonna go with Miami with the most
beautiful people in general for me Miami
you got New York you got LA some
beautiful people I disagree Toronto
Toronto Vancouver Toronto not so much
Vancouver to here YouTube they got the
Asian thing going then yeah they got a
nice Toronto Toronto is astonishing
Toronto is a perfect melting pot with
honey yeah Toronto is Jojo Gershon our
boy he's got that town lockdown and some
would say Drake but yeah
carry on Drake Drake - let's say Drake
have item.i I was astonished I like
running through the six with my pants
off yeah I didn't know that I've run
through the six with my [ __ ] out really
yeah now are you 10 Hunter you all soft
be soft and floppy floppy floppy depends
what I'm doing now when you run if you
ever runs full speed with a hard-on and
do you get a red welt
oh boy I heard well I've done it no you
have it sure half well probably maybe
got caught doing something you weren't
no you got to bust a load and someone
it's like hey what the [ __ ] that's my
wife
now you come running away your dick goes
zero to a hundred hundred to zero I was
in New York City because New York City a
girl
had this very big apartment I had a
hard-on she shouldn't just bring you up
she goes if you ever run top speed with
a hard-on I go I'm gonna and I didn't
even I looked at her and I sprinted to
the end of her hallway and then I
sprinted back and belly she's I've never
seen that and my dog was gonna quit
douche what douche and I had a little
red well like yeah a little red well
comma Tommy goes down like I had a red
welt about six inches above my belly
button but you can't maintain that no I
can't they just I think your brain just
shuts off that part of your body and
you're running yes have you ever said to
me have you ever had a hard-on or the
beginnings of one and had to go onstage
in two three one go no okay no I mean
you have dude I was uh some of the lead
singer of Led Zeppelin was there name
Robert Plant no no it's the guy when he
left
well Jimmy Page Led Zeppelin it was it
lets Epling Led Zeppelin there was
nobody who left Led Zeppelin it's the
greatest band of all time now I don't
get I don't get upset
what's another band that's really big
okay van Halen who's on business Sammy
Hagar yes yes give me some man I think
Sammy Hagar yeah was on Howard Stern and
they say cuz I guess he wrote a book
about it and lovely one of the biggest
bands of all time yeah he was getting so
many chicks dirt and hold on relatedly
rock there was no Sammy Hagar clear off
the heat down I know but this is him
talking on Howard Stern and in his book
he got so many chicks during their
concerts he had a handler they'd go find
girls yeah like just dye amis they had
to build a tent underneath the stage in
between his like didn't you'd go down
[ __ ] girls and then come back up to the
stage is that true yeah so in the middle
of his concert they said all our Sammy's
tent again underneath all our Sammy's
tent that's the major just lifestyle
they'd suck a mop they
jump back onstage and they said
sometimes like they'd they'd be doing a
bit and he wouldn't make in time they'd
have to keep [ __ ] going longer and
they get all pissed off at him what yeah
that's so weird
well three about the level of that's the
level of depravity well there's a first
level oh yeah I mean when you're that
theme yeah you know rocky got a song
before he joined man hell he had a song
called I can't drive 55
damn it was like I can't drive that back
well he's really good most attractive
man though is he now again he looks like
oh he looks like one of those troll
dolls yeah you excite your truck oh yeah
he know you look blond Rock Gym ron
jeremy oh god he wishes he just looks at
your troll doll it's tough - it's tough
to troll goes I'm sorry I just got that
yeah you got it right
those he looks identical to that's
exactly what it looks like right there
it's strange to watch like those uh
those like hardcore literally the rock
stars of like the 70s and 80s yeah and
then fast forward now yeah father time
just doesn't [ __ ] around no he doesn't
he doesn't yeah come here let me see
your tip yeah let's bring those down and
then oh you like food we're and pull
your love handling you know give you a
belly here yeah and then you're here oh
yeah there we go and then your teeth let
me genuine up it [ __ ] she walked back
it's just I and they did other drugs
they [ __ ] all the girls yeah but let
you know what to live Sammy Hagar's life
for that 10 year run so worth theirs it
was so worth yeah you die down by dude
you burn it at all at every end for 10
years man I think this what's the
biggest song chin it says right there
can't drive 55 right oh well that's and
then what was his what his band you you
said he was in Berlin Van Halen but then
they had uh I never liked his voice much
I love David Lee Roth scores his voice
was too high-pitched all due respect to
him yeah hey do you know any of these
well clay why no all eruptions I'm here
right what what here that this is just
nobody done this on a bit on a guitar
Ellis
what this is Wendy van Halen was like
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
rock stars don't exist anymore - then
now this nobody was doing this back then
this is in 1984 feel like who's how's he
doing this on the guitar every guitarist
was like can you play eruption is it
just the music it's just a solo him
grinding like so fast yeah he's just
like yeah you're imagine just [ __ ]
leather pants on stage just you know
what he said he said he got to a point
where he wasn't making mistakes on the
guitar anymore he started playing the
piano
yeah they say he's amazing at the piano
- one of the best of them play this play
on the show chin lay this play play I'm
playing run in weird the devil running
with the devil turn my life I try to
example what's your [ __ ] but running
with the devil just for a second you're
mine you don't know any of these songs
your own analysis I know the song this
song oh well they were um they were this
is Rhonda Grace album creeper oh go to
[ __ ] what mm smacks gave it a thumbs
down turn this you imagine going let's
put it given a thumbs down I picture me
my friends just [ __ ] gene shirts on
sleeve for this [ __ ] trend then we
run by your rich-ass and got this white
polo on you know I can be ID and I'd
push you down no yeah rich boy look and
I'm like this train your daddy like this
she did a big target on me [ __ ] she's a
big target jack I will kick you what are
you gonna do buy my wheel kick I'm what
a great song man oh you just can't be
yours there's no rock stars anymore put
on ain't talking about love go back
what's this what's this it your another
Jam I gotta get my guitar hold on
oh I wish you could use this audio audio
go for it then I hate Van Halen's gonna
bring us down no we can't use any of
this though right yeah you've been doing
podcast way to turn up for I am podcast
for nine years
[Music]
that's a long the drums yeah I knew it
man what's all your mouths or to solve
and get that solo what happened
oh the mic that little bit helmet makes
me gay oh hey we know you become a great
yeah our fine anyway if you want this I
you just picked up some water with this
okay boy that van Halen oh I get it Ben
Halen it's weird you become like a
groupie of poopy when Van Halen hit I
don't remember what happened I just suck
me off dude is weird yeah yeah you're
like run into the devil and then trying
to suck me your chair is just off
miniatures are always very [ __ ]
oh no we're good man I'm sorry about
that oh I get it then Halen does I just
see red and I don't know what else is
going on I'm like that with the bad
sheep I just have this need for guys
Rick I got a need for God
oh I hear van Halen I feel meaty I
[ __ ] love when that gay friends who
act like straight dudes can be turned
it's my favorite some can yeah I knew a
hair stylist was like I had a boyfriend
and we used to pull straight boys
because he had this bubble butt and I
just put him out there and the straight
boys well those straight blows like
those my boy yes because there's no dude
with a bubble butt that I'm gonna go
like you don't understand how it work
now all acknowledges ass yeah like did
she get the house of that one well my
favorite is my acting teacher I've told
this story before where max teacher
would be talking anybody like it's like
you straight guys in college you suck
each other off you go through your face
and I'd be like this I'd be like no I
don't do that I've never done that I
haven't sucked anybody off he goes like
this
I go I go I've never done that he goes
yeah yeah sure sure
and I go I have any mmmm great huge
mustache cat you have no idea who Van
Halen is Sonya too young I know the band
don't know their music man legend you
did a good job defending me off of your
dog not really your pretty hands I get
in there yeah you used that [ __ ] you
had a talk to use the shovel technique I
get the shovel in there had it wrapped
around my thigh I was how he did I was
wondering do you dude speak you missed a
show on Monday with the chicks from a
caller daddy probably better you missed
that one yeah I mean me and Cynthia had
fun they're good people
yeah you'll need young cows young gals
killing it 24 years old 25 24 good yeah
they're harassing chin about his sex
life gin did not feel comfortable Iver
II pretty girl parties the brunette is a
die me dying judge yes gorgeous
good lord good for them and funny
obviously since is a humor yeah and well
whether you got yep
there you go it's a woman's time you
guys it's a woman's time it's a long
time what did you what else do you do
this weekend did you you did the ice
house why I did that I saw some Friday
right uh what else I do just chilled man
just chill bro okay
I sell since
Friday that's it so the kind of store
last night your girl Tiffany has from
there dude she's so pretty in person
she's so gorgeous
ah I've known Tiffany so fair so careful
she's always been like Giga gorgeous I
know you never know Tiffany no I don't
know her at all
she's grave done a couple shows all
gathered last night was the first time
tiffany has always been a really good
gal good person I'm know I've known
Tiffany since she was man I don't know
I've known her for 12 years yeah really
pretty she was a kid
you started the life crisis you know I
said Tiffany one time I was like Tiffany
listen you could be a star don't be so
vulgar
I'd say that she was like yeah whatever
no she shouldn't shut the [ __ ] up thanks
Brian [ __ ] up she's just sending Kevin
Hart on rogen I loved it
I wanted you to listen to it yeah
anything you've heard I heard seven days
before yeah I love Kevin so you know for
me I love Kevin I love Kevin was it I
didn't hear the end I love the message
he gave yeah liked about the haters and
he doesn't listen to that and just the
way he deals with thing my only critique
of it is loved it but I felt like Kevin
went in with an agenda like had a plan
going in which I like I want to combo of
two of the most powerful men in
entertainment Rogan and Kevin like that
we're at a coffee table yeah you know I
think Evans very thought out God now in
that situation you know that's what
that's my table yeah that's my problem
it's not a problem I enjoyed the [ __ ]
that Kevin's with my favorite people in
the world yeah and he's a pioneer he's
an absolute legend yeah but I felt like
there was an agenda of things that talk
about the have you heard Rhodes say less
words on a podcast ever yeah you might
said seven words yeah it's just coming
with and then my supp wants bring up
someone's have this this is oh I didn't
hear that Marcie I didn't get to that
part yeah easy guys like I'm starting my
own supper why not and then it's this
out of the calf [ __ ] do you know he's
pitching all this and I don't know I
hear he's a bit he's a businessman yeah
straight businessman so ten one of the
most generous people I've ever seen in
my life
generous did you watch a special I
didn't I'm going to I'll see he's a
monster yeah it's weird because it's
filmed in a
in arena his face makes me laugh just he
just makes me laugh yeah they both make
me laugh when you when you stone stories
about [ __ ] uh patrisa oh my god when
he just here making laughs the Patrice
O'Neal song he laughs when we said he
was just not sad without reading through
a phone book on stage ah but that's
better material brother I i sat with
Patrice now only once with dub Davidoff
I hit I didn't know Patrice you know I'm
very very peripheral you know who he was
oh yeah I knew hoses I know from New
York I would do shows with him but I
just never really spoke to him he was
kind of standoffish guy and I didn't
hang out down the cellar my club was too
calm comic strip and he's like you're
aces but yeah yeah but he well I was
with with Dov and he went through his
philosophy on how women have karate how
they use a certain kind of mental karate
on men and that was the theme and this
movie while sitting down this this dude
you know me I'm pretty skeptical this
dude broke down like male and female
psychology on a level where I looked at
dove and I go to be holy [ __ ] and dove
just went the man lays down a heavy
truth telling me it lays down a heavy
truth and he just went on and I and I
was quiet the whole time and I went this
dude is very smart dude he was like
ridiculously smart I guess he was like
he did everything his way and I've had a
good bite him in the ass yeah just as
far as business-wise well that's why
Kevin said his not give a [ __ ] miss had
a dark side to it's always the case you
know I mean he was what did he die from
I think diabetes a heart attack
something like that
it's a shame not healthy and it's just a
[ __ ] amazing and amazing it is a bummer
when someone dies like that how about
him
guys it fer Kevin Hart and Jim Norton
was like the crew in New York in Rio
they'd all hang out you got this crazy
and then and then by the way throw in
greg Giraldo throw in yes dubbed Ava
doll throw in Chris Rock throw in throw
in aw it's his name Jesus Christ I'm
getting old Mulaney no black comic
the great black comic Jersey Chris Rock
not Dave Chappelle huh
Dave Chappelle would be their all-time
that wasn't that he's Duty is 41 you fly
a table Brandon you in there yeah the
tables so cool
yes Colin Quinn they're always there oh
yeah it's one thing that that hurts my
heart like that that one of the things
about standup that's so great is that
that is how we all used to hang out at
the Laugh Factory get out the Comedy
Store not enough anymore we need to do
more of it like just to hang around
because it used to be that was the table
that we'd sit around and [ __ ] I feel
like you're the counselor especially in
the back there or the parking lot late
[ __ ] yeah eight man yeah yeah it's
it's the way it should be
so it's run everyone's in town not on
the road the comedy at The Comedy Store
is as good as any comedy ever in the
history of comedy in my opinion right
now this guy was shot right outside the
comedy face I don't want to remember
that Josh Nasar in the parking lot
that's why Security's there damn my
buddy Josh held him while he died I
think I was reading or I finished
reading that book I'm dying up here
where they'd the show time did the
series off of it but the books white
been in the series the series made it
like no one was having fun when everyone
was having an awesome time and killing
it with Jay Leno Dave Letterman freaking
all the guys Robin Williams but that one
guy Steve hurt chin or something like
that he jumped off the roof he commits
suicide [ __ ] yeah yeah he jumped off the
roof and commits suicide man like he was
when they were going through the strike
then finally they're going back and
Mitzi to him like was he giving him [ __ ]
e spots music on that he wanted to make
it so bad and then he said he thought he
was like sacrifice this like he thought
he was like sacrificing his life for the
better high roof either the hotel that
white hotels not oh he jumped off that
yeah into the parking lot but if he but
if you talk to most accounts he just
wasn't very good
he wasn't that there wasn't then we're
giving spots trying to [ __ ] him he just
wasn't very good yeah
Steve there it is I don't know dude it's
like I can't imagine jumping off a
[ __ ] roof forms
jumping off a roof you know it's weird
is there was stats out that well the
people who when they jump the people
that survived which if you thought your
life was shitty before and now you're
drinking I was strong you all your bones
are broken you're being wheelchair so I
mean two-way words but all of them said
they said the first thing they thought
of when they jumped was I wish I didn't
do this yeah I've heard that and I've
heard that with the the bridge - yeah
with that [ __ ] gold do you think uh
people jump off there 24 a year
something like that it's the number one
suicide place in the state there's an
iOS thing about number two what SS Park
Isis bar maybe check out top 10 suicidal
place in America I'm going Gate Bridge I
want to say SS Park is up there I always
think about this woman who wrote a
letter and she said if one person smiles
me on the way to the bridge I won't jump
and she gelatin use it not one person
but yeah and it makes me so sad man yeah
this is 1500 people hated most popular
locations uh China they don't count cuz
I make an iPad so they freak out um
going gate bridge Toronto Whitlow
keishon is iconic yeah there we go
scroll down chip for the love of God go
to United States you're up the zinc
right North America going Gate Bridge
boom Colorado Street Bridge and Pasadena
have you seen that place no official
count halt at 997 to prevent record
breakers San Diego cuñado bridge Jesus
Christ George Washington Bridge okay I
was lying about Estes Park I don't see
it up there I made that up you know I
was told that from a guy that I did a
haunted bridges Niagara Falls who the
Wow well did you ever see that guy in
viewers they were doing the news and the
guy ran by her and just jumped you see
that you ever seen that on TV
sure haven't you commit suicide yeah so
there was like a like now the woman was
speaking and he just ran by her and see
if you can find out Jim hey we're not
making light of suicide here guys you
know I know we're just looking well
place is out again run and if you're
feeling that way please talk to someone
what was that bye it was on the
and she was it was like the 70s or 80s
and she was just talking and a dude
genocide during live news broadcasts but
but the Niagara Falls Niagara Falls yeah
I don't want to see other ones yeah me
neither
welcome to fire kids faces of death yeah
exactly
you ever seen face to death sure that is
yep cat your way to younger faces death
chin you saw faces of death many of ya
pray on it
I'll never watch that stuff again
Niagara Falls jumper attempt suicide
caught on tape
man goes over Niagara Falls mmm sure is
Niagara Falls cuz people go in barrels
and just go over the side and survive
all the time yeah I mean some died but a
lot of people survived it hey there in
the wooden barrels let's go over the
side we get turned all that guy Steve
lubricant or whatever but they were
saying he was he suffered from mental
health issues it was it that yeah and
also he was a I I don't know this this
is what the the rumblings on the new
ground is is he was a bad comic but he
just wasn't funny so he was at having
success right it was it and he wanted so
bad yeah that's what added to it yep
make masseuse on live TV Jesus there was
a really bad one do you remember when he
took a shotgun to his head and they were
filming it from helicopters and
everything on life model in the news and
this is before they started doing the
delays also had an idea yeah so everyone
saw this guy and they did it off yeah
well the one we watched that one here in
Larimer Square we're in Denver dude you
remember jumped off the roof here
everyone's on lunch break Romero I know
do we watch in here whenever square
right bike the right next to the the
copy words Oh everyone's on lunch
regular Tuesday
Larimer Square Larimer Square I jumped
off roof in Larimore squared M my friend
saw that in New York he's walking on a
date first date you watch somebody just
hit the ground
hello the first date yeah oh there's a
lively video battle on a lot yeah but
that's what we watched on here before
hey I didn't see which one of us has CT
for fine every time
I know we did watch this the four of us
watch that maybe had a dream
no we watched it and then Brendan said
that he need to text Jay yes this is all
right yep oh man watch it go ahead and
watch it so you but I've seen it I don't
think how come I don't never this guy
does a cannonball right into the cement
well we shouldn't watch it because
because why brain well are you gonna
fence the one yeah I'm saying I wanna
make light of this
we're not hey Judd Apatow relax I know I
just don't makes me feel so bad well I
mean but it's just [ __ ] that we have
nothing to do with it we're not
highlighting it this happened a couple
weeks ago over in Glendale - at the
Americana someone jumped out the
mechanic watch young people it's not
let's let's keep this comedy I feel bad
about it what's wrong with you makes me
sad why well but nights terrible but
we're not burn upbringing I mean right
this has been out for a long time yeah
it's amazing we already talked about
either way it's amazing what you have
zero memory of this how about what you
can see on YouTube like I like the hot
that's not eduation so no it's not no
hostage situations well you see like
like certain countries where the guys
like I got a knife on the person in this
sniper goes I'm gonna now shoot you in
the face oh by whom are the Chinese that
one thing that blew me away I was on
Instagram the guy's got the woman
against a wall they [ __ ] lower the
Chinese guy by his foot down with this
gun just cuz I'm gonna shoot down the
top of that not bad oh [ __ ] what you can
see some badass [ __ ] you know some of
its fake though is it yeah but you have
you seen like these martial arts people
that a woman that comes in and their
stuff yeah yeah yeah some of its not
there I hope so you can see where you're
like oh no that's not fake yes but she's
like Russ or some [ __ ]
yeah rush ism oh you know what I saw in
Russia and I think it was real this guy
was a prankster [ __ ] the guy was a
prankster and he would he would get into
mailboxes and when you put your mail in
he would push your mail back out well
I've seen that sold and then there's a
giant guy put it in he just put a gun
and pulled out a gun and just shot it
into the [ __ ] mailbox
he just went I'm serious killed him and
you
how's the guy dodging I mean he's just
in a mailbox in the guy just he was so
it was like the 90s it was so clearly a
gangster
he was so clearly a giant gangster he
discussable he just goes dish dish dish
dish will now you've ruined your mail
yeah
video clip shows there's this false oh
it is ache well this is according to
Snopes alright
false good good good but it's old Kalin
yeah a lot of them are fake a lot of the
prank ones especially are great super
fake well are you trying to go viral
yeah in Russia when the guy would scream
at people go like that do uh like that
you did the guy start doing in Russia
yeah Russians were like really every
[ __ ] Russian to start punching and
punching kind of well like they'd have
training mmm yeah yeah well no suicide
in Russian mobs yeah suicide Russian
mobs bootcamp videos yeah erm er square
ones like 2 years old I want to say wow
Sears I couldn't talk him down
no they talked them down yeah if there's
a way you can have a drone waiting like
a fast drone with a net like a giant
drone and they should jump the drones
like Katja do doctor that one time I was
coming down I think it's the 91 that
dude was gonna jump off and I was in
traffic for 3-4 hours cuz then I was
right front row at front row tickets to
this and right the cops stopped it so he
couldn't go on so we're all just sitting
there and there's buses there's cops
everywhere sit three hours into Chicago
you should that you should see the
regular people this old lady was like
just [ __ ] jump man if you can just do
it I'm gonna right here you're [ __ ] up
it's it's the most selfish thing to do
like if you're gonna do it [ __ ] do it
and let's move on with our lives
well same thing I almost almost miss got
late late to my gig because there was a
dude on the overpass it was you know
holding on and the cops were talking to
him as I went by still you know they're
kind of moving us very slowly he's
yelling at the cops he was a little
crazy
but I feel if you're doing it from like
this guy didn't jump they got him down
you if you're doing that that's just
straight attention just want attention I
always think about how like people will
jump and kill somebody in the car like
idiots or or that Mike the craziest one
is there's a honeymoon couple they're
driving in their car I think it's in
rush or somewhere no it might have been
actually well you watching so a Russian
bid I think was the main something and
they're driving and a dude just you know
in he's retired he's got his fishing
gear he's in a pickup truck he's driving
this way and the [ __ ] honeymoon comes
like I love you ever had such a great
time in a bear bear well I go with a
Babu they hit it like toss beat the bear
they hit it so hard the bear goes flying
in the air into the other lanes the
through the windshield I know it's not a
video
true story it goes through the
windshield of the guy driving his pickup
truck and kills him he died by bear he
died by bit that happens with horses to
died by flying bear died by flying bear
it's a myth but no it's a true story see
that's a true story told you that I read
it here at from a very reputable source
on the Internet
no I don't remember exactly but I read
it huh and I remember it was very
reputable I'm sure in somewhere in the
world that did happen what's this mmm
see if something happens yeah couple
killed by bears you mean a couple of
Hyman hot bear traffic
yeah wife of man killed by barrack
scaped with her life after playing dead
yeah you know really that Boy Scout
leader they stumbled upon a [ __ ] bear
cave he's like now don't worry you just
got to lay down and they're not gonna do
anything with you and the entire
twenty-something Boy Scout tribe watched
you get eaten alive ass first oh my god
not the way you do what the [ __ ] you
doing it's the easiest lunch ever right
ask first homeboy yeah they should move
on from death yeah yeah we've been the
death podcast this face of death final
condition I don't know if you can buy
those phases of death anymore so savage
know you can you know I'm sure someone
uploaded on here whatever the [ __ ] you
do I was listen up
change up I was in a podcast of Adrian
Foster he dives into the
the Michael Jackson stuff oh yeah man
hey I mean I don't know if I did it when
you look at the hard evidence this and
they have like lawyers and here's all
the all the the documents everything you
look into it like where it's actually
started in 1993 with this family
yeah and they have the dad talking the
stepdad about the son I mean it's some
shady [ __ ] man
so it started in nineteen for this one
deposition of the of this family of this
red that that's why I read that article
it was in Vanity Fair I didn't read this
article simply this is way bigger than
an article in Vanity Fair so it dives in
way deeper and they have recordings of
the Cerreta down a step down and the dad
and stepdad are talking and and Michael
Jackson defense team actually played
this in court and so dad going man if if
we do this you know we're gonna get paid
and like this is one never have to work
again and they wait a month to say
anything she then they see a therapist
first he's got this son this is getting
dad yeah so think about let's say your
son was molested so just say just just
just common sense your son's molested
yeah and you find out once you go to
3800 you worry about there's no money
there's got money what I think I'm
thinking about my son's mental well ball
all the actual people who tried to take
Michael Jackson in court everything's a
money play it's all money
I mean you listen there's nothing on an
shil evidence like Fox well but here's
got royally [ __ ] but here's my thing
he did spend the night with kids so that
that's my question
I know is he just weirdest [ __ ] I know
dude did have the parents come out and
said yes he did separate us and yes he
spent that much time like is that just
no just the parents that were trying to
get money from and then how about okay
the parents go we need 30 million
dollars right that's what that's what
there's no amount of money and then you
have to go to jail attack I go I'd say
like your money touch my son you have a
cell no listen you have a pedophile so
what you do is you go there's not a
there's no amount of money at first
first thing is my child's well-being how
do I heal my child how do I deal with
this second is I have to get this
pedophile to not do this to other
children if you take 30 million dollars
that's blood money because
you're taking is you're making it okay
for him to continue to molest children
if you're gonna settle out of court
that means you're putting a price so
it's so you so how about the amount of
money I can give you to [ __ ] a child and
that's what we're talking about so
that's who you are as a person computer
so and that your de facto a bad person
but think of if you're if you're this
family and you go i we don't have you
know I don't want you serve time justice
doesn't need to be served
just give us money like hold up that
ain't real man no there's no amount of
money in this world that you could give
me that if you touch my son I wouldn't
want to see you [ __ ] rot in jail
also you want to protect out the
children what are you very strange well
but all that amoral anything all the
accusations are the same they're all the
same it's all money driven everything's
money driven everything you don't hit
you hear the kid after the fact
where can I hear all this agent Adrian
Foster has a sock Arian Foster
instead of football player yeah he was a
football amazing football player retired
Arian funkin so Charlamagne tha God now
Arian Foster yes so what is it he has a
podcast his podcast okay
there's better that he's great but
obviously he's not a he's not a lawyer
he's not a but he's just want to change
my mind it's interesting he gets really
deep into it really really does a good
job if Sonu doesn't have that background
it's a great job that's amazing yeah it
is it's interesting listen doll and he
goes he starts off he goes listen I'm
with everyone else I thought Michael
Jackson was guilty I won didn't think he
was guilty but when you actually cut out
all the hoopla the media all this stuff
and you look at the actual facts and you
get into these cases and you go case the
case I mean I should get him on the pond
cause it's just not there wow it's just
not taking our boy Aaron on the podcast
he's on Rogan a while ago yeah we should
get him on though yeah is he living that
way I don't know stud football player
really retired now but was a super stud
I'm retired early position running back
I'm Arian Foster yeah amazing player
mm-hmm okay for a while I'm a dude now
has a hit podcast
kill him again so cool there is not an
Instagram there is I think it was a
quarterback from
I think the Raiders he cracked me up
he's like I miss you Jimmy huh those red
98 Mississippi
Hado brother Jimmy all right he was it
you know he's a quarterback but he talks
to the to the defense all the time he
goes he goes the defensive player goes
man run on the outside let me get you
one of me gets a can he goes I would you
know I want to brother you know I want
this is live in the game he talks to me
back he goes you know I want to brother
I would I give you a sack I just can't
right now I gotta I gotta win this game
this talking to I love that [ __ ] talking
trash the [ __ ] is his name a human man
hell yeah bro if I was a quarterback I'd
be like that I bet I Brendan it's our
brother your player your defensive end
yeah like red 98 blue 14 I don't know
what all that means bad like when they
say it blue 14 what does that mean I
don't let's go to Colonel Vance top
Brandon you look good bro I like that
chain I mean we've established it off
though on Instagram it's Russian fake
videos and then football yeah yeah and I
also follow boxing royalty right all
right what do you got cat so Dwyane
Wade's son Zion went to Miami pride with
Gabrielle Union and Dwyane Wade wasn't
able to be there because he had a game
that day but he posted up videos and
photos of him supporting his son being
at pride is this son gay mm-hmm oh he is
Evan yeah
he's knows he just knows she at least
you know it was Gabrielle Union and his
siblings as well but is it their kid
because he has kids this is a kid that
looks like elationship
yeah he looks identical at Dwyane Wade I
was gonna say but they also have a kid
together right yeah they just had a
gorgeous she's 40-something - yeah he's
11
yep 11 and just [ __ ] doing it do you
know about that time you know when your
son did you know did you sell are you
speaking from experience I didn't know
until he started playing van Halen yeah
I knew I was so weird but I did not know
that would I mean up and I say this I'm
not trying to piss anybody off I'm just
saying if my son came to me and was like
dad I'm gay I'm not obviously on my
alright cool man like I don't I don't
all right whatever your best life so
they a piece of me would be like yeah
dude yeah a little bit was just like
damn yeah he's not gonna have a regular
wedding I know how other people view gay
especially the Catholic Church and like
it's me it's up you have a tougher Road
unfortunately you have a tougher or
nowadays you have an easier road
depending no no no maybe in Hollywood
not in the real world you know in our
world you might yeah I'm the real way
III think go go to Nebraska or go to
Denver be gay go to Idaho be gay
yeah it's gonna be a beast changing and
a lot but I think that I'm still a tough
gig yeah well I think I think also you
know you're you you your son as a boy
there are certain things you have in
common with him and there would be
something that you didn't have in common
with him necessarily until you come out
of the closet why don't we both coming
out of it just it just be a tough pill
to swallow no pun intended tough I have
used my dad would you do it I have
friends who who have gated kids and they
know you know they kind of could tell by
the time the kid was five and six
they're like oh boy well oh I went to
one of my buddies house and hit one of
the littlest kid it was all hey I'm like
well alright yeah
you'd rather in shoes just like he has
no idea he's just like hey well and he's
like dancing around like Branson really
alright cool then I I will he has more
sugar in the tank the rest kid yeah I
always had a I was a furniture store
there's a long time ago I was gonna buy
a really expensive furniture piece of
couch that had won an award
why because I'm number one a sucker
number two I was told it would be the
only cash that was fitting my
quote-unquote space she's and three
amazonica
and three on the sock and you watch fake
Instagram videos there's a lot of issues
right now also award-winning what like
what award did it by the way that's best
couch never a Saskatchewan Party never
asked oh wow never asked and the couch
I'm not gonna tell you what's crummy
Mehra's that make me not know what to
cost her back in the day it was so
expensive like I didn't have a lot of
money grand 12 grand what and I was like
I know and that and and nowadays
actually if you go to Restoration
Hardware not that's that's you can get a
12 grant Kiser and that I don't know if
you can get a couch from a long time ago
it was so expensive and it's still clear
12 grand is crazy but I was like
like I can't pay that and then my friend
was the designer was like yeah you
should and this is why I would go broke
and spend money to please is this guy
gay or what's going on here so he goes
so he was gay and so this kid this
couple came in and his kid who was like
seven this boy
laid down clasped his hands together
like that and threw his feet up behind
his body and cross them oh behind his
neck yeah I like cross them you know how
you cross him anyway like you like a
stripper behind the net well yeah but he
was laying down like this Oh gotcha as
he did that he goes I love that color
and the guy was selling in the cash
designer goes well we know how that's
gonna go
that's funny no is it I was like
congratulations on your K trial I think
a lot of sometimes you don't know but
sometimes you have a child who's very
effeminate thought it matters me yes I'm
done you just tell ya even Tigers
clashed just like oh the kid has a
little sugar in a steak well told you
that my son in his class there was a kid
they all were told to draw a face and
one kid I was with the mom one kid drew
a [ __ ] face that had like blood red
eyes fangs and like black it was it was
such a YouTube thing though dude it was
so scary and and I and she goes I said
well it was so blatantly obvious that
this kid has such darkness or something
so on YouTube she goes I hope so because
he wasn't really watching YouTube is too
young so she goes she goes yeah she went
she went yeah I don't know
I said well she goes I said it's
probably just a thing you know he's just
imagine if she goes I hope so but I
don't think that's the case I mean if
you do it all if he's doing all the time
yeah yes I said I hope so bad I don't
think that's the case but sometimes I
might be a serial killer
Tiger watch YouTube he it's 30 minutes
the more in three minutes before bed so
in the morning sometimes I'll look over
and some scary [ __ ] yeah I'm like what
do you doing dude boys like he said no I
just was like your thing that sticks out
on their videos when who's [ __ ]
putting that in here for kids now boys
boys
like that [ __ ] yeah I like it my son had
a [ __ ] fork and he was stabbing he's
preparing to stab you in the [ __ ]
laces like you know sword [ __ ] sword
final give him a store he's happy so
Dwayne Dwayne Wade couldn't make the
parade though mm-hmm yeah they have one
or two kids together just one I think a
baby girl mmm and Dwayne Wade retired
last night by the way he did and Dirk
Nowitzki he already how long has he been
playing to it with like 17 years I mean
all the way that long forever really
forever [ __ ] I feel like your timing
playing for like ten years no he's the
same draft class as uh LeBron Bosh
Carmelo Anthony's yeah I feel like you
LeBron yeah LeBron how long seven years
he's been playing for 17 years how the
[ __ ] does time go like that again I
thought wow how much longer do you think
LeBron has oh I don't know I'm sure it's
in your current events Matt Johnson yeah
yeah I met Johnson retired today T
stepped down as the president the Lakers
so I don't know I don't know I think
LeBron when he came to LA thought it'd
be a little different you they're having
a harder time guys don't really want to
play with LeBron they're not signing
these big free agents they thought they
don't want to play with know why I just
think he's uh you know what those other
big free agents we play LeBron he was
playing second fiddle and no one wants
to do it anymore
so and it's a bit of a [ __ ] show the
Lakers right now yeah Matt Johnson
stepped down why is it significant
because Mack John I mean Matt Johnson
the one who's you know brought LeBron
here he's the face of the Lakers you
know he was supposed to he was supposed
to be the savior for the [ __ ] Lakers
they've been shitty forever and then he
even he just didn't tell his boss his
boss he just did it
look I'm told that HIV to take a [ __ ]
hike because when he came down with it
was a death sentence I remember it very
well when he came down with it it was
your who my brother start crying when he
got announce he did J start crying yeah
so weird and he told he was like ah yeah
I'm B all right [ __ ] off
yeah Jani bus he didn't tell her he's
just like hey I'm out so now yeah Lakers
a little bit of [ __ ] show I read about
this a little bit so they're saying that
he when he's part of the Lakers he can't
really talk to other players
like you know like high-value whatever
for your president yeah allowed to
recruit exactly or even like talking and
congratulate them for stuff so this is
sort of a play they're saying that so he
can actually start getting these guys
for the Lakers afterwards there's so
many contract rules that you can't do
this and that yeah like we can't do his
job like with Anthony Davis who's like
one of the biggest free agents
they said magic was tampering with that
and they get big fines like you got
fined $500,000 and he also said he just
wasn't having fun anymore yeah he was
like this just isn't great yeah and
they're also saying like he's he's at a
level right he wants like a seven
thousand Starbucks tunes of Magic
Johnson cinemas like he owns right he's
a co-owner in the Dodgers knows the
Dodgers right so he's a billion he's a
bit so they're saying for him to be the
president the president like is at high
school games it starts at the high
school so you're recruit in high school
kids you're seeing the biggest prospects
in college or you're kind of on the road
you're grinding you're [ __ ] you know
making you get your eye on the prize
yeah they said Mac just wasn't that guy
like he's he's a billionaire so he's the
face he's he's not terribly he's trying
to put together see he has a bunch of
connections we can't talk to those
[ __ ] huge free agents who are under
contract with other teams so since
taking over at president of Lakers Mike
Johnson never fully come into the job
often he was traveling away from the
team his office his office hours were
limited he didn't do a lot of scouting
running every team takes tremendous
commitment of time and energy was Adrian
watch he's the ESPN it's NBA insider and
then you there also so also Luke Walton
suppose be fired today just a lot going
on with the leak and they haven't talked
to big drama support you watch more
everyone I'm you don't watch baseball uh
I watch baseball just in October right
but I keep up with it I keep up with it
but I'm not like balls deep in anything
but football fighting and your mom oh
you son of a [ __ ] what were you say Jim
knows it it's on see it's a little bit
of a bad look for LeBron because they
call him like that they good dynasty
killer the coach killer everywhere he
goes don't just get fired
I'm sure he had something to do with
this as well really a hundred percent
Lakers aren't making any move without
LeBron
LeBron shouldn't [ __ ] space space gm2
is he
that's another Kurt of it that the Greek
freak turned it down that that that guy
turned it down and then it's also hard
to cast people because everyone has
these freakin sponsorship deals right so
LeBron has Nike Steph Curry who would be
part of it has a good yeah Under Armour
another guy has adidas and yeah he's a
natural actor like in I think it was
called little foot or whatever he played
was the voice so you don't know that
good to hear you though no but he didn't
train wreck
he's that is he's great yeah he's good
yeah yeah it's it but I I like the Greek
freak who was like nom I'm not going
Hollywood man this guy's the best player
in the NBA who the Greek freak from
Milwaukee Bucks almost seven feet tall
because he's from Creek and he's a freak
he's from Greece he doesn't look Greek
saying he does I don't like being
Hollywood he's such he's so [ __ ] good
you never see no mercy no no my guy is
really yeah young obviously started well
probably MVP this year place for the
Milwaukee Bucks y'all having a hard time
putting the Space Jam I thought I don't
know that's an ad that's an African name
no [ __ ] by anything he's from Africa
you said he's Greek his family raised
him and I got you split African descent
yeah he looks after he looks fairly
athletic there he looks fairly athletic
hmm okay
super beef yeah yeah everything to this
cupping [ __ ] have you tried it no damn I
want to try I've tried you're gonna try
it no way we talked about it too because
I have bad muscle pain in my back I
wonder if it'll how it's good like I've
never had like problems with my knees
when I was fighting or like not my back
it dropped like to some of its like
fermented like dead blood in there so it
like [ __ ] brings out the supposed to
do it's getting new blood in there true
though no it's true I've seen me what I
know Olympians do it so I don't used to
do it at home one are scientifically
that's actually something that works or
is it placebo all I know is the biggest
athletes in the world LeBron this guy
who have to access to everything and
anything can imagine things you haven't
heard of they do it yeah I'm sure they
do a lot of things but yeah
there's something to it I've seen a lot
of yeah I've seen a lot of big-time
athletes do it so I acupuncture it maybe
it's it it's interesting yep mmm what
else yet you oh so there was a hacker
who would basically go into different
people's IP address to figure out what
they were watching in terms of porn and
then he would send pop-ups to their
computer saying that this is the FBI and
that you're going to be like get in
trouble essentially or we're gonna watch
I each had a file [ __ ] it does not spend
like Robin Hood a porn it I think they
were targeting people who are watching
weird [ __ ] because I don't know why you
would do that with yeah otherwise it's
like yeah FBI thing popped up on my
screen smaller I was watching like some
Brazilian girl get Brock this morning
whatever all right
FBI have them come in lock me up yeah
okay yeah good make sure I'm not [ __ ]
jerking off while he do it actually make
sure I am well the guys that that he
actually had people send him 200 dollars
to keep quiet and he made a couple
million dollars also feasible I'll see
you think watching some bad [ __ ] right
that could be it but also you really
think the FBI is gonna let you send them
cash to get you hey FBI here's 200 bucks
he made millions of dollars
yeah 4.5 but for some reason they can
only account for a couple hundred
thousand dollars four point five million
dollars which he spent on jewelry and
sex workers and drugs he was killing it
for a hot second
he actually teamed up with a Russian
hacker who taught him how to do this and
they split the profit Wow caddies Dylan
offers for your feet yeah people keep
anything I do they always send me DM z--
or no no they don't say let me see your
feet yeah they do all three oh you
thought I asked you see yeah Rendon
we're on the podcast is what people said
let me see your feet yeah Hubert send me
offers for pictures of my feet I mean I
feel like you could do it what is it
like a patreon thing she could do pretty
much anything though don't I actually
ask people it's like half the people
serious or not and I think half like
people actually are because that first I
thought was just one big joke chin are
you interested in showing your big feet
people want to buy it for sure my feet
are nice action please put your [ __ ]
feet on do you see I want to see you can
raise money hold on chin if you can
raise if you can raise $100 oh you can
right now if you can raise $1500
I will [ __ ] double it and give them
it the out dawg I'll do it this size
twelves on an Asian it's like a rare to
whatever homeboy bro I like I try to
sell it though set it up want to see my
feet butt chin put on what you put your
feet like a diamond shape and put a
banana in between I can speak and hold a
banana Chin's you eat hold you make
money if you posters a picture your feet
home like hold on that's X that's pawn
that's on the menu you can have your
yellow squishing a little toesies in
jello you can have your feed in holding
a banana no have a whole new edge plant
an eggplant that's extra
see that's the deluxe package yeah yeah
jimm package yep I'll just show your
feet just covered in oil oil not
chocolate put icing all over your toes
past your toes covered in icing your
chocolate icing tree nut chocolate white
white and chocolate
nope just flies I'd be so [ __ ] why
he's such a Puritan let's get crazy
look I mean no flakes your toes up
someone that you toes just and then
there's a huge closet and then you've
been your foot resting on it you just
put the hashtag cozy what I want to pay
me to not see my toes this is if you
guys want me to stop just tag cozy man
is it you holding up would be cozy and
your feet rub stuff and write up some
[ __ ] you know you've got some friends
random yeah while you're eating we're
gonna be good games now chin oh hey I
don't think so I look just all you gotta
do is this you just put out anybody want
to sit on my toes there are plenty of
guys who'd be like I'll do it or girls
I'm sure some girls are in defeat are
you an effete cut I'm not into feet but
I feel like if you have gross feet yeah
yeah that's a breath to know you must
get hit up by guys not with feet though
no but I say even doing it as iam oh
yeah I didn't wanna bring it up until ok
huh
that guy said you make you [ __ ] oh you
make me [ __ ] and he had squirt squirt
like an imam then had a picture of his
ass wait he was he was that position
remember I told you if he's on the
position his foot but butt naked yeah
and in a mirror so he took a picture of
his face but you could see his his his
crap his whole yeah and he said
something else like I'm wouldn't least
have that I'm gay or something or gay
that's very you yeah like I want you to
[ __ ] me that's right I wanna [ __ ] me
it's so intense give me your address
I'll be right there
on my way it's so intense I was even if
I was a gay guy but I did he had a calm
down I was sick that's so yes it looked
like he had died his hair was hacked
wearing half a wig it was something here
he's wearing having an alley cat version
of [ __ ] Wesley snipe from demolition
man yeah
the alley cat version the feral version
yeah the version that had been living in
an alley so and how do you take that
picture you have to be creative that was
good you know a lot of that yeah you do
guys and girls yeah a lot of girls what
else he had chin yeah you look like that
but shitty he looked like was he sniping
if he did math and then wanted his ass
was it's a really [ __ ] nice guy met
him a couple times super nice guy cool
alright so a group of kids in Fresno saw
a woman standing next to the ledge of a
bridge and she was gonna jump and they
actually talked her down that's awesome
that's cool speed of jumping good for
you kids though thought that whole crew
talked yeah
the their school's volleyball team
that's the volleyball team yes good for
those kids where's that at Fresno yeah
that's pretty cool you can see a woman
looking at a bunch of kids going I can't
show them kids no I bet also was that
picture of the bridge yes I break her
neck doesn't like too rough yeah that's
terrible
good for them stop it her man oof yeah
hopefully she got help after that yeah
she was on a psychiatric hold for a
couple days yeah I'm gonna keep her
there huh what else you got man
let's go I thought this is awesome this
is in Ireland so I I guess the gangs in
Ireland they do some crazy stuff they
actually took a construction crane and
then dug a hole into a building to get
the ATM machine out I'll show you how
they did it to his cartel out there
needs money that bad the way they did is
legit you'll see this guy coming through
and I'll fast forward it and that's the
getaway car that's the supposed to take
the ATM machine it's you box it in that
little mini truck yeah and they actually
cut the top of that truck open alright
there's these operators these are dudes
these are Special Forces guys or
something let's not that much
credit special time houses look how
crazy things a special force so there
were Russian guys who were special
forces in the United States who were
doing this they were part of a military
unit in back in Russia and they were
they were sawing ATMs in half with a
chance he goes off for a while they
destroy the entire site ability grabs
that forever it's four minutes total
that's that's impressive pretty fast and
they just drop in thing yes you're here
that's I think it's cut car comes by
they have not caught him yet how much
are the ATM backs up grabs that cream
and to work enough and I thought they're
gonna try to like put in the back but no
he drops it right on top right here
watch she's pretty good with that thing
that means unless some big we puts it in
there yeah so it's sticking out of the
top of the roof dude leave the thing
just shaken up [ __ ] [ __ ] and then you
say Dodge George get the [ __ ] out of
George Wow chin Google how much money
ATM Seth I'm sure there's a standard
grant just no no wait not more than
fifty fifteen thousand dollars there you
go as much as $200,000 hours most
machines contain less than $10,000 Wow
yeah they're not gonna leave two hundred
thousand dollars in every machine
because of this yeah they only have that
ten to fifteen thousand dollars of them
that's all that I mean after you read
that stuff ten guys after taxi you split
it with how do you split it with homeboy
and I'm sure you got a boss see four
grand night yeah how much dozen ATM way
let's see that I mean doesn't matter
it's better luck in jail to our fifty
pounds sorry about that yeah well we can
rip it on the [ __ ] wall but yeah
mmm-hmm okay what else we got um no one
MMA one sure assume it's TJ yeah I
really watch that [ __ ] man so he was
headed to your suspension do you know
what he popped for you just found out
about this
I love my life you just found out about
it hold on yeah no I'm from last night
yeah I know it's been everywhere yeah
all you do follow UFC yeah very cool all
right oh no gamma tell no no no yes
supposedly he's a UFC Fan I am no oh
wait he's gonna say TJ's his friend
during this now cool all right yeah
awesome yeah no no I know TJ's careers
over okay thank you the so I was last
night calling that was last night yes
don't call last night like that sorry
dude come on man I'm busy I've been big
I know me too though I know yeah I know
I know I was scrolling through the
rushing [ __ ] tapes instant pop up
for you know I'm always like I'm just
you know in my own world but hold on I
was on a plane I know all right well
what guess what you popped for Brendan
actually predicted predicted this and
like other fighters might be popping for
the same thing guess what it was okay
not the normal estrogen blockers no no
come on that's child's blood um I don't
know
EPO they can test for EPO now yeah
they've been able to test for but now
they have a new way to test for it and
you saw doesn't gonna tell everyone but
now that they have this the most like
stringent testing in the world yeah now
they can test for EPO they couldn't
before so a lot of guys they're above
the system right so they're they're a
little ahead of it but they do offer you
size number okay guess what if you're
taking this we're gonna test now so they
don't tell you so we're gonna see more
guys to stop but he is like this T it
just hurts you know why I get two years
you know I get two years they went back
and tested an old sample as well so when
he beat Cody the first time he was hot
as well on the CP oh yeah this is my
problem and this gonna take imma take
some heat for this I do not think it's
right to take old test results and and
dictate whether the guy was clean or
don't use in stuff just how far back you
want to go to tarnished Owens let you
see how far you want to go back name a
fire hammer how far you want to go back
be with you you want you want tests
force grip for the Stephan Bonnar I'm
with you want to do that you want to go
when there's no testing I'm right how
far you want to go back you want check
chocolate on Tito what about Randy
Couture and I'm not saying
guys are on this stuff yeah I'm not but
I'm with you with the new testing if you
want to go that you want to test my
sites you know that rollin you want test
Mike Tyson Sadie oh he's the greatest
boxer of all time
you want to test him yeah you want to
find out what he's on how far back do
you want to go to bring down the
foundation of mixed martial arts I agree
cuz if you want to go that far back and
go well TJ is just of you know a few
years ago all right it starts there I'm
guarantee as the then this white
fighters need a union I need of
Association dude hold up we're not doing
that you're gonna ruin everyone's legacy
agree people well they should be clean
people have never fought but you don't
know what the [ __ ] you don't realize
that and I'm not saying they shouldn't
be tested stringent like strict now but
how far do you want to go back before
you like is you want you love and silver
right I do phenomenal fighter right the
best you are testing when you're not got
Vitor Belfort now why not I beauty
refuse on anything now
okay I understand this is a contentious
subject and I get it but this is this is
how I this is what I how I stand on it
who's your favorite fighter am Susilo
and did you want to test them do I
appear what test George run is run sure
don't I don't let's say let's say
because let's say at the time what jor
when George going through that run I'm
not saying these guys are anything one
same is the testing out so I'm telling
you this this is why I wouldn't test
them it was a different time in a
different sport in the sense that there
wasn't this testing in the sense that
from my experience talking and seeing
how fighters fight the pressures the the
need to stay injury-free
the needs every one of your [ __ ]
that's it you're with your opponent
who's also doing whatever they can it
was a different time the key what's the
key there though they're doing
everything that they can to that's right
this is a heart of professor Schwartz
right will you watch NBA NFL and NBA
hundred-percent named name of you the
favorite player you Nolan right and why
is one testicle around what proof you
test oh and Ryan you want to go he was
great right don't know I don't I don't
like how far do you want to [ __ ]
bring down he's not you see but see the
reason I don't as it doesn't take for me
it doesn't take away from the fact that
these are great athletes it really
doesn't because I think being a great
athlete like George st. Pierre like TJ
Dillashaw
like like the other guys you mentioned
it takes so much more than just drugs
there's so much hits the problem was
society go oh
steroid user he should come back screw
you just what I tell about John Jones
when people you're so hard on John Jones
mmm yes however I said whether John was
using [ __ ] or not still he's still the
best fighter on the [ __ ] planet
that's he doesn't read this great also
his opponents can be taken ten times
what he's taking he still beats them
that's hate to tell you TJ taking EPO is
not the reason he lost any pseudo it's
probably not the reason why he beat Cody
Garvin some reason why he knocked out
Cody Branch I thought the reason why I
knocked out Soto it has nothing to do
with that correct but people see these
headlines go he's a cheater that's only
may dismiss him I'll do me a favor
everyone who's gonna critique TJ
Dillashaw or John Jones or whoever's
fail the test take what those guys are
taken and go fight another man the rock
gun yeah let me know how you do go fight
a man and not even in the Octagon just
anywhere go see what happens go compete
on the on the level of these guys
competing on I'm not saying it's right I
said what and TJ should be suspended or
more free on to your life giving what
I'm saying is going back over time going
through old tests is not what we should
be doing yeah because it because the
testing is way more advanced now does
not mean we should go back and tarnish
the legacy you can do that with
everybody
dude I'm how many how many fighters
question oh honey you didn't ruin let me
ask you something you know you know the
sport deeply and you know it intimately
and you train and you train with a lot
of the greats you know a lot of [ __ ] you
know a lot of [ __ ] and more if I took
these tests that we have now and I went
back and tested don't say any names hold
on if I tested every [ __ ] fight that
we all know and talk about I want in you
or if a gun to your head right now
everybody's [ __ ] thank you do you
don't have a UFC thank you if I'm Dana
I'm cut and I you know I'm calling up
and it doesn't called up Jeff this gave
me like dude I see yeah I know you guys
doing great but he doesn't work for you
Silas so I don't know you if you I don't
know what you do if you're Danny white
because how far back do you go I don't
know how far right they can go cause
you'd have to have those samples but if
we're gonna start going oh you bring up
old [ __ ] and we'll keep going back all
right man
you're gonna
ruin me see what good it does do it in
the NFL goat who's your favorite player
oh you like them at Smith let's test him
in 1993 you like Michael Irvin Troy
Aikman when when it was just the
free-for-all test those guys you think
all those guys who's your favorite who's
your [ __ ] face your guess is all
those guys everybody impress boards you
like David Robinson yeah all those guys
Oh Alonzo Mourning test them let me know
how it goes for you it's just in but
people like though everyone's clean this
is a click no it's not drugs are a part
of professional sports the same way a
referee is they go hand in hand it is
part of the game some are better at it
than others some have more access to it
I'll be dead honest with you i 100%
would have done if I had the money
didn't have the money
could I have done it yes didn't have
them I couldn't afford it yeah couldn't
afford it but if you put a gun to my
head and so on it Brennan if you put
this needle in your ass you will become
Cain Velasquez so to put that needle so
far up my ass or she was probably my
dick hole course you were when you were
still afforded when your wife well why
because I was 27 living at my brother's
yeah and drove a Dodge Ram yeah I
couldn't afford much yeah and you come
to me and I know other guys are doing it
and you can make a million dollars two
million dollars three million dollars
you you tell me what's wrong with that
beer well it's unethical no it's not
that is part of the game that was part
of what I was introduced into the game
everyone is surround I always find
myself here's the other problem when the
coaches go my love problem to to is to
TJ's coach comes out and goes we had no
idea we don't condone this you know in
takes zero zero responsibility for this
I have a hard time with bang no not
better calivita guy three words in
tablet if here I have a very hard time
that cuz you wrote and [ __ ] ride it
and died with this dude when he's not
gonna be buddy out and when it's
condition blah blah blah and you're
gonna tell me and here's the other thing
everyone's gonna go you're just
defending TJ blah blah blah
here's the other thing you do not do a
PPO is a black belt level drug
performance and EPO is a EPL's not like
what bikers weed feels not like you just
took deck into the ass or went strong
then you figure it out
the EPO is a black belt level [ __ ] EPO
is the most dangerous PD you can do as
well thickens your blood you have to be
tested all the time so has to be on top
of it you are not doing this with if me
and Brian I got in the Tour de France
did and stuff at the highest level yeah
you guys do it all the time yeah but
here so here's thing if I'm doing EPO
it's not like yank bro you want where
the CP offline I heard it can help you
know what's gonna be out test why you
want to work oh no you have a team
that's monitoring your blood levels your
red blood cell levels your white blood
cells and your cholesterol your blood
prep it is the most dangerous you take
too much your blood gets thick and you
die Jesus and when this is why you Lance
Armstrong ago I'd have to wake up in the
middle of the night and get on my bike
to thin out my blood I could feel it get
beat because if you're taking so much
your blood gets thick Jerry dangerous
very expensive you better it's it's not
an entry-level drug right is the [ __ ]
black tar heroin of drugs like you
better be on it man damn so when I heard
TJ got popped this one this man cuz cuz
you again if we're doing drugs and after
you marijuana no biggie
Kate wait entry level drug right sure
you smoke a little weed now if we're
doing drugs then I give you [ __ ]
black tar heroin you like what I don't
know where to inject this right we got
to start somewhere right
you just don't start with EPO that's
what bothers me it bothers me that it's
EPO it's like y'all [ __ ] man that's some
high level [ __ ] and there was a team
around this and there's a team around
this somebody's coming up the throat
everyone's don't TJ under the bus yeah
the guy who supposed to be this mad and
I've never met this guy for great things
about I'm not [ __ ] Nam but this guy
who's supposed to be this mad scientist
who he GJ moved his whole camp out here
and all this goes we got nothing to do
this we had no idea [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] man then who then
house T how did this all go down
how was TJ taking it for this long and
nobody knew yeah come on man
and you guys are like this he moved his
[ __ ] camp out here for you because
you're this mad scientist and he tests
hot and you have nothing to do with it
rolling away [ __ ] in a way also TJ TJ
made that decision for his own body so
it is his response hold on oh no no I'm
not letting TJ off the hook yeah I don't
want people I kill you just defend TJ
I'm not defend TJ what I'm saying is I'm
sure there's some other [ __ ] going on
the two cuz EPO do you not just take an
EP and put on your own you need you need
a team doctor you also like that some
[ __ ] previous you also need doctors you
done you have some experience work yeah
you need a [ __ ] someone who knows
what they're doing like I contend I
contend this I I think that none of
nothing surprises me when an athlete
gets caught doing something in this is
no no never insanely competitive sports
specially done what would it take
anything away from the fact that he's
one of the greatest fighters September
Stephanie hawk it does though brunt in
society no he's [ __ ] yeah well I think
that seed then matter how far they gonna
go back I have a problem with that
though let's not judge too hard that's
all I'm saying well that's the sign
that's obvious
I know but so but it bothers you so
let's say you're Cody Garber aunts dad
yeah
and cardi Cody Garber got not got twice
by TJ Dillashaw
I don't think it was about yo I think it
was because of skill you're his dad
you're not thinking that way if you're a
Cody Garber a friend you're not thinking
that that's an emotional issue so well I
won't i won't include Cody grunts dad in
it
I won't even include Cody but what I'm
saying Mosport why would I say it do
that B if you're Cody gar Brant
and you've all you've lost two fights
title fights yeah - TJ Dillashaw and he
tested hot in both of them you're not
gonna be like that so no he's getting he
got suspended for two years and that
that's why so you have to uphold the
suspension you get caught you're gonna
pay a price what do you do with those
sites what would I do with those fights
to me I think TJ still beat him fair
fairly in terms of he knocked him out
and I think that his skill set his
ability to see holes in Cody's game but
it's what got him to win he understood
how Cody Cody was clean
still think that TJ beat him using skill
and not with EPM that's that's my
feeling but you know what listen I'm
with you yeah by the way yeah again I I
find myself kind of feeling heavy
shaking my head because I think it's a
bummer this is this is why she said rear
of two years there's no wife's can just
rush yet his level this wife shake my
head
he's [ __ ] now anyway cuz we're talking
about him even I'm like oh I don't go up
40 J well I do go over because I know
what society and the fan base can do -
did you yeah he's like seasoned meat all
right shake go easy and here's the other
problem behind wish the other promise
that the his team grow now we didn't
know so what did TJ really I was just
this coach that same [ __ ] oh my god
dude what are you doing also that that
wording how long did that take you know
it sounded weird like he's trying to act
smarter than he is you actually read it
he's as big words you read it Christ
what the [ __ ] dude yeah like you
understand all of it but it's like you
went through a dictionary at the little
[ __ ] exactly that's what it sounds like
like even right here the training lab in
no way condones encourage our family of
athletes worldwide to partake in
brilliant downward spiral or helix of
synthetic performance Danson's to do so
is not only harmful than invisible
harmful the brothers sisters and I
fairly much I'm not buying it I'm not
buying it it's all gonna buy this
apology the way it was written the way
it was worded I just go oh well I guess
this if anything hurt him well when I
read this went oh when I watched the
CrossFit Games there's this documentary
at that camera was called and one guy
got popped for steroids and the other
CrossFit athletes like especially the
coach was like boys a piece of [ __ ] and
you cheat well I have to I was like look
is there all along don't go that bad on
a guy who gets caught everybody's doing
it we all know it's CrossFit though you
should do it you do it
let him oh hey why don't you do it
you're lifting weight and running right
why wouldn't you do it
that's a this what you do for cross I
just don't like when they go that bad
I'm one of their guys for getting caught
he's a peaceful guy when the guy was
like two five [ __ ] Martin Maguire
that's some [ __ ] and then you see he got
busted to think all right or the guy
goes the guy who goes dude that guy's a
[ __ ] he's gay bro it's like chill man
guys cuz you like that's right yes and
so those people are real mad about yes I
think people love to see somebody fall
and it takes away from the fact that
jailers trained harder than you can ever
imagine and harder than you ever have
what be here's the n-word on such
incredible competitors TJ TJ with
away from hold on TJ with elite amongst
the elite exactly so so take anyone that
uses your favorite fighter TJ out
training them correct now here we go
it's because the P oh no now dude
there's been there's been in circulation
for ever on TJ that he's been taking
stuff forever
yeah well test all the samples I bet for
a fact more EPO pops up he did you set
something to show our enemy is out of
line now gar Brian actually tweeted out
something like two years ago saying like
your EPO is helping you something
specific about EPO to to your dildos he
knew they'll know they'll train I just I
just think that he's not a coward TJ
Dillashaw is a great fighter and a great
champion and I'd still don't think it
takes away from how great he is I just
don't hide I ain't helping you know no
I'm saying it's not helping his legacy
no it's not helping his legacy and it
would help if Cody got huge price two
years that's a huge price for him that
could be a career that could be you know
I don't know what you do with it though
man I don't know what to do with it I
feel bad for TJ I feel bad for Cody I
don't know anymore I don't know what to
do with it to be honest I don't know
what to do it people go you want up
you're forgetting peewee oh well you're
such a flip-flopper because you went
hard at John Jones I didn't go hard at
John Jones well I went hard at John
Jones was the [ __ ] excuse people
were giving me yeah I went hard on
Nowitzki and it's just pulsing it's just
now you're just using and everyone is
but he's still the best I just hey I
just thought you know I don't like I
like when you [ __ ] me
this is what I do that's what I don't
like when it went with something is
going on and we just go that's all good
man it's just pulsing is because took
dick pills from a gas station come on
come on you tell me the best fighter on
the planet Earth I like the Vince key
though because he was pretty he was
pretty sympathetic to the fighters in
terms of these tests are so [ __ ]
accurate that they can pick up [ __ ] that
may have happened two years ago that's
what I got from it and that there's a
lot right they'll be if you did two
years ago you did it last week when's it
right well so so I think the way I would
deal with it is this I I think that if
you want a truly clean sport you are
always gonna be racing against
technology but it seems like these
testings are actually ahead now the
athletes for the first time I my
question is if somebody gets caught a
great fighter like TJ okay I totally
agree with going back going back as [ __ ]
yeah but going back to bullet I don't
like it but but let's just say now we
have now broken things you should go
back yeah but he goes you should test
them all medium we'll start with some
you know I mean me and Rogan had a time
series becomes I went your show off dude
it would ruin the sport for everything
it's worse that
everybody everybody would come up
everyone and so I don't really want to
see that I don't think it's good for the
sport I don't think it's relevant I
don't
what would I would I think that you know
what I what I would like to see is I
would like to see um penalties not be
career-ending when you suspend somebody
for that long who use that seems like
really a long time so you know in the
Olympic it's four years yeah but every
day on dicks is every four years so I
can deal I can kind of live with that
choose two years your code you knew TJ
you're missing out on let's say
conservatively four fights four years is
four title shots basically I don't know
man I I find myself kind of shaking my
head saying I don't know to you know
about this because if you want to create
an even playing field you have to be
super strict you have to make the
penalty something people are terrified
we're to make the downside not worth as
much as the upside right so III I don't
have anything I don't have answers
either I think the testings too strict I
think too precise sir it's too much guys
are testing positive for [ __ ] and
then in in couldn't society if something
gets leaked and then it gets out guys
are [ __ ] you know even if they weren't
taking stuff see this makes me they cook
with Kobe I mean Yokota I could eat yeah
it's like you got knocked out twice yeah
but that builds up from a dirty fighter
don't be yeah I don't think the EPO
helped them I don't think the APO is
what knocked him out have you ever taken
EPO I'm on it right now when I'm just in
a van Halen it's like my EP a-- have you
ever do never taken it no if I can
afford the regular drugs but I think
what Joe does it oxygenate your blood
and you don't get tired it just keep you
can just keep going right
which at 125 135 yeah hold on
is everything not just a little thing be
everything everything skews koteas I
mean some of the most amazing skills in
the world
TJ has some of those same skills in the
world so if one guy can take something
he doesn't get tired yeah how when did
TJ knock Kody out the second round right
yeah was it late in the rounds yeah so
again I think I think in this case I
think TJ I just had Cody's mom but y'all
see obviously the EPO didn't help him
against Henry cejudo no y'all knock down
45 seconds yeah
so you being first down than early in
second round yeah so yeah yeah so just
you solder right what that's like that's
like the only real fix is to just remove
USADA well if you remove all you Saadat
you're gonna have pride I know it's back
in the old you seen it I think then
there becomes well you just we can must
give the Commission yeah then you have a
shitload of pressure on fighters to do
every drug and I think you just not so
you know I don't have an answer yes
answers you'd see like yeah it's the
best thing for the sport is to clean it
completely up when you launch is what
they're doing I'll say something kind of
controversial when you look at Bellator
I mean when you look at was it fs1
what is that one that one j1
championship I have noticed maybe I'm
wrong I have noticed a little bit a
little difference in the Air Force
yes but let me ask you this is that
product better no I really was once I
soon he texts me about a1 championship
fight right once that thing it takes
about of Bellator fight right what's
still the UFC yeah yeah I mean I just
watched that [ __ ] I rewatched the T
city and Brener tiya and Holloway what
I'm what an amazing fight what I mean
Hotel away yeah up until the fourth
round but I mean yeah [ __ ] was a rough
flight for Brian yeah um I don't know
what you do is the answer well the idea
is to protect the fighters from
themselves to protect fighters in
general
ideas have great fights the idea kids to
keep the sport as dynamic and exciting
as you can and the idea is to keep the
sport as fair as you can right so so
that's what they're doing
yeah it'll never be fair though right no
well life isn't I mean it limpets tried
to do the same thing look at the
tampering gone with the Olympics with
Russia no we're gonna be fair Ikaros
everything it's just people are always
gonna try to get an advantage what else
about Sam that's pretty much it that's
pretty good yeah that's good well I'm
sorry about TJ but I don't know what you
do I mean again I'm not making excuses
for my adult Lee the only thing that
pisses me off is them going back in time
are they gonna do that for I don't know
I don't know there has a suspense
history they don't give a [ __ ] here's
the problem the fighters have no no
recourse well they have they can't do
anything yeah you see when oh we can go
back to 2004 uh who's gonna argue for it
no one no one what do you do what do you
do
nothing you do [ __ ] yeah I got dial
thing views he's gonna do that then I
can do that they know what's up yeah I
don't want to see because I think they
just want to back - what - December 1
how the hell that thing was two years
ago
well they went two years ago I think Oh
- the Cody Garber is like yes Jesus
Christ man that's too much man I don't
think you should be doing that others
beg to differ
oh we solve nothing
yeah it's interesting right on appeal
Brian's on it seems like when you when
your castle on steroids like I'm not
cats on steroids I'm IPO it's funny that
when you start setting you asked me the
question I find myself scratching my
[ __ ] I know right and that's okay
magic is your job - tough one I'm on the
right thing I think you and I if is
really if you put our feet to the fire I
think what we would do is we'd go you
gotta have testing and you got to make
the penalty scary enough so that you
don't do it well two years is a lot it's
a lot that's the Cody
Wow
test all his samples I bet for a fact
more EPO pops up you I'm sure we'll
learn more a little bit later hey Pedro
Martinez who knocked out Cody grabbed my
early Shearer was flagged for elevated
levels of testosterone okay well i'm
pedro muñoz yeah I don't know man it's a
hot [ __ ] bath you know what I'm glad
of I'm glad that it's not my job to
figure it out it still a great fighter
still a [ __ ] phenomenal fighter just
just this Barry Bonds still a great
baseball player save me so so still
great baseball player Sam Brian koushin
still have a linebacker
Roger Clemens one of the greatest to
ever do it regardless Jon Jones pulsing
or not still the greatest of all time on
a percent Bryan Callen Branca throws
chest he starts shooting it up I just
need
I just might Mike Phelps hoping my
[ __ ] EPL bro I was hoping my my
physical where he was like testosterone
was really low or something anything you
do and it and I just need one exercise
what would you even do if you told the
doctor into EPO you'd like mine yeah all
right well let's wholly render this on
up bad let's go back to suicide that's
good i casa
yes inch dies it's good to be back bone
me out come see me this weekend Friday
Saturday at the stage New Mexico hmm I
told you son play stage at Santa Anna
Xena
I'm excited who you bring with you I'm
bringing my buddy Justin half monster
Boston comic funniest [ __ ] so come see
me at the stage santa ana star casino
this Friday Saturday the 12th and 13th
two shows each night and then Denver the
25th 26th and 27th then YouTube
you steal it for my mom bro we've been
nope we've been honest you know what my
mom she her birthday was two weeks ago
yeah here's all what for my birthday is
lunch with Bryan Callen I will give it
to her I mean I meant lunch hi men I'll
give her a good lunch
I'll get on watch your face twitching
for to take it easy
look it what are you feed my mom I'll
give your mom the meatball sub we're
gonna take our time that's fine like
that huh okay you get talking that time
yeah it's gonna be hot sure no problem
can it be I thought my mom wear a dress
it's gonna be long love case you like
long hot dinners as lunches and I'm
gonna feed it to her no that's fine it's
nice to be fed yeah where you gonna go
my bedroom hey sorry your room service
yeah oh I make room service okay yeah
you think you're like a turkey server
yeah well I'm gonna I'm gonna get like
it all over my room service yeah I know
but what do you think like specifically
kind of food well I'm thinking about
some sort of meat yeah yeah I'm thinking
as far as food is concerned I mean love
my American boner it's my mom do sorry
I'm gonna suck you in a phasing if you
get if you bring nubby into this man
take it easy if not be do you feed uh be
if you know please what do you give
nubby if watch your words she's you know
I love a hubby I don't but you know I
have a pen shop for the free yeah sure
like British stuff he wants to hang out
yeah what are you a feed uh B I got
stamina my American boner okay you know
what all right man well you share stay
away from nubby I can't wait to see her
and not be in your mom yeah they they
what they do want to see you I want to
see your boy J I want to see Klopp I
know come out in Denver and Miami free
tickets on Brian May night yeah name a
nine ten eleven Joe get your [ __ ]
tickets but New Mexico this weekend
Friday Saturday I'm tell you it's a good
place yeah I got some you want jumbo I
saw my buildings it wasn't my MMA
friends coming out I don't know what
that means I am in Phoenix end of the
month Phoenix stand up live in hot-ass
Phoenix Arizona two shows Friday to show
Saturday that is April 26th or 27th then
Tampa just announced and that bad boys
going fast Tampa and prom a 10th 11th oh
but your Miami
yeah that's far from Tampa dude you bore
city you're at the improv yeah great
place I've been there before dude Tampa
May 10th through the 11th and then just
announced Cleveland steamer if they
sleeve it I'm dropping Cleveland steamer
even Steve come and get your Cleveland
steamer I mean Cleveland May 30th
through June 1st take a dump right on
your chest Shaw will [ __ ] on your chest
even T fat K calm Phoenix I'll see the
end of the month
stand-up live TV a calm I'd say my
sister when she was the first year in
college she dressed like I was college
she goes well there's a really nice guy
were talking to Lee [ __ ] I fell asleep
and there was a pause and she goes and
they take the [ __ ] on him I go steve is
that what's called to log off on this
what did they give me the definition of
a Cleveland I was laughing so hard she
was like how can you laugh that I go did
not final thing I've ever heard him I
wanna make a shirt of a train it says
Cleveland on it and the steam coming out
Larry took a [ __ ] on his chest Cleveland
steamer poor old soul even steamers a
sexual act they're involving [ __ ] on
someone's chest and singing in it and
rolling back and forth like a
steamroller steam that's greater role in
it
alright well this is the fine kid we're
out as he did that he goes I love that
color and the guy